welcome to our events and we're so
grateful to all of you for coming today
and we're celebrating Joey don't
and his painting of the diamond
mountains we've been titled this
restoring Korea's artistic heritage
because of the restoration process that
we went through to bring you the
painting that we lawndale this evening
so thank you very much I know how it's
kind of a hectic game you are today so I
really appreciate everyone for coming
my name is Theodore gears and I teach
modern Korean literature in the
department of East Asian languages and
cultures I'm also the director of
undergraduate studies in that department
as well as director for research I am
going to keep my remarks to a minimum as
we have a number of speakers this
evening including experts on Korean art
history and restoration conservation you
have extended biographies of today's
speakers in your program I would like to
give you just a brief introduction of
the speakers who's the director of the
CFR used a library here at Columbia he
also serves as the vice president
president-elect of the Council on East
Asian libraries
Alexis Mack adorned is the head of
conservation for
Columbia University Libraries she serves
on the visiting faculty of the Pratt
School of Information and library
science and the concert Conservation
Center at the Institute of Fine Arts at
New York University Cairo shayana is Xin
chào professor of Japanese literature
and chair of the department of East
Asian languages and cultures
he specializes Japanese literature
visual culture and cultural history he's
the author of numerous books and has
co-edited inventing the client including
co-edited project inventing the classics
national identities gender and Japanese
literature that was translated into
Korean as the children go John go
Annunaki John John Young Saeng Gua kunde
good Eagle gender and published by some
young it was some impressed
Eleanor thon is the curator of the
Korean collection at the British Museum
and Eleanor am I right you're the first
to hold that position
so you are the inaugural director that's
really an important global position to
be the head of Korean collection of the
British Museum so we're so happy for
anymore she completed her master's
degree at Columbia
mber PhD at the University of Chicago in
art history she was the recipient of the
Jane and Morgan Whitney fellowship at
the Metropolitan Museum of Art professor
song and Kim is here and will talk she
received her PhD from UC Berkeley and
his assistant professor of Korean art
history at Dartmouth focuses on early
20th century in Korean art and culture
we also have a special guest this
evening I'm very grateful to Amy Lee
Yagami aza who's sitting right here for
accepting our invitation so kind of
accepting our invitation to join us and
unveil the restored go ahead on painting
as well as she'll also make some remarks
Amy Lee worked as the Korean Studies
librarian at Columbia for 27 - I have
that by 27 30 years from 1969 to 1996
she is the author of Nile G weekend well
my father Prince Regent she's the
granddaughter of king gojong the 26th
king of the Joseon dynasty and later
ever
we can see many things in GUI Don's
painting including the modernity of
tradition and of course we can also see
a vision of the diamond mountains that
goon gang saw in the mid-nineteen
thirty's the painting can now refer to
something go--he dong who was painting
in a colonized but you know a unified
Korea likely did not anticipate in the
1930s and that is the question of
national division and reunification most
of us haven't been to the diamond
mountains the mountains are located in
North Korea and the tourist access that
opened up the South Koreans in the early
2000s has been closed
think about the painting and Gogi dalam
and of course this shows how we can
extend the idea of unification to a
broader global context and community a
community like the one that is here
tonight at the star library far from the
Korean Peninsula a community that has
been brought together by modern Korean
art and a great artist coeval we have
another community also a diverse and
local one and that is the group of
people also brought together by go
Edelen a group that has dedicated itself
in different ways for years to us to
restore this painting gloom gongsun the
painting that we are here to celebrate
tonight a painting which is one of a
series of codons works depicting the
diamond mountains I believe I would
particularly like to thank Jimmy Chang
the director of the Star library ever
since Jim has arrived from UC San Diego
at Columbia he has been a tireless
advocate of the Korean collection which
is one of the largest in North America
and its support for the effort to
restore the painting Gong Gong Sun has
truly been impressive he suction our
Korean Studies librarian has also been
key to the project so thank you Jim and
he sued the Department of East Asian
languages and cultures at Columbia
provided full funding for the
restoration and I would like to thank
him for his unwavering support for
Korean Studies at Columbia alexis
Hagedorn head of conservation at
Columbia spearheaded the actual
restoration project which was carried
out with the utmost care professionalism
and deep respect for the Korean artistic
heritage by hisashi gucci and jennifer
perry of asian paintings conservation
and they're here with us as soon as well
this project was carried out in close
consultation with Eleanor Kyung have I
mentioned now the British Museum as well
as consultation with the well known
conservatory professor of Bach ji-sun in
Korea tonight's event is supported by
the center for Korean research and the
CV Starr East Asian library with the
assistance of the Korean cultural
service New York at the Korea foundation
and the department of East Asian
languages and cultures as well as the
weather heading station Institute and I
would like to say that we would not be
here right now without the
organizational acumen of Jiyeon Kim the
CK our program coordinator who has been
working on tonight's event continuously
for the past eight months Thank You
Julian where are you
I don't see you she's back working there
she is in the back and we give her a
round of applause perseverance combined
with the sense that we would succeed I
will tell you that what I know about
these things I learned from many kind
people who extended themselves to me
during the years I lived in Korea I am
reminded of something else when I look
at and think about gory Dawn's painting
and that is the global Korean community
who has entrusted us with this work of
art and more broadly with the teaching
of research on Korean history literature
culture and language at Columbia all of
us who have come together to work on
Korean related materials at Columbia at
the Center for Korean research the Star
library and the department of East Asian
languages and cultures are very grateful
to have been given this trust thank you
all again for joining us this evening
and please stay after the talks for a
reception we have prepared some
delicious food for you and I hope you
enjoyed it and I would like to turn now
to Jim Channon station library I will I
thank everyone for coming to join us for
this historical moment of unveiling
restore the painting up by the famous
korean painter cokie dawn we're not our
most important treasures in our
collection
I would like to thank professor pet
who's director of the Center for career
research for his the critical support he
last three years the sitting the library
to restore the painting and his
leadership he colonizing today's event
with the excellent problem everyone
enjoyed later and also most importantly
I would like to thank to our experts our
conservatives our consultants your
knowledge your experience your
professional walk safe and Abby stop the
glory and the beautiful of this special
feature thank you and we all know the
money cannot buy everything
however without money nothing will
happen for that I would like to thank
professor Horace Johnny and the
department chair of the department
estate in language and cultures and the
professor Bob Heinz and the former chair
of the Emacs and the young man I made
this in heaven
finally I would like to thank the
support of the Columbia University
Library mushishi conservation define God
his property in the my colleagues in the
star library for the project and the
preparing for tonight's events please
also take a look the related Coheed on
exhibition in the to display cases were
there one here they tell you about the
art the history and our latest special
painting prepared by law Korean I bring
this machine thank you
as the chair of the department of East
Asian languages and cultures I'm very
proud that this event could have
occurred
I'm particularly proud of our Korean
Studies faculty and if you'll excuse me
I'd like to name them because they're so
important
Charles Armstrong in modern Korean
history he couldn't be here this evening
Ted Hughes whom you've already heard
mouths does so much director of this
Center for Korean research
Juwan Kim our pre modernist in Korean
history
Carol Schultz our director of our fine
Korean language program boom a song he
saw Hyun Joo II and Kim Yuna's job has
just joined us and we're going to run a
tenure track search
this fall to bring in another the I'd
like to thank them right now
for all they've done for this program
when I became chair of the department
about two years ago one of the first
things that came across my desk was a
bill for $36,000 now it's a little bit
surprised I thought oh you can buy a lot
of books Korean books for $33,000 but
the more I learned about this project I
realized how much value this project
disband and it's kind of because it's
been such a long road involving so many
people I appreciate it
even more today and I'm really glad he
lack our
could fit the bill on this so without
further I do I'd like to turn it over to
the specialists in the field and look
forward to their presentations thank you
very much
thank you
Columbia University faculty members and
staff in CB Stein station Everett
tractor and staffs
for preparing this exciting event and
I'm very honored to give a presentation
on this very important painting of
cojito now on display at the famous
turkey station library and thank you all
for coming here and not going to see the
Pope Guido is often called fire first
western-style
painter of Korea it also said that when
we don't was alive he was a classic
after he passed away he became history
and his life encapsulate the history of
Korean Modern Art from the last phase of
the Chosun dynasty through the Japanese
colonial period liberation and the
Korean work to the foundation of the
present socio-economic system of South
Korea and he was not only a painter but
also served as a founding member of the
Korean artist Association as a juror for
many national art exhibitions and later
as a member of the Korean National
Assembly whose entire 60-year painting
career and his other achievements are
very impressive but my talk today will
cover three points first our first
briefly discussed who knows life
including his family background
associates and contribution to Korean
art history then I will discuss the
changing meanings and representation of
Diamond mountains or kingdoms on
in Korean history and artistry diamond
mountain is called Kumgang sang in
Korean but here follow correct I'm a
mountain for the benefit of our dong
Korean audience members we will also
look at the tradition of Diamond
Mountain painting before we do miss her
third and finally I will discuss the
significance of time of mountains to for
heat oh and look at some of the post
tiny mountain paintings including the
children who have changed waterfall and
painting in the sea beast our East Asian
driver collection co Eden is a
descendant descended from the remarkable
church called tuning family the tuning
of a social class in the fetanyl in the
church learn Korean falling between the
ruling elites called young man and the
founders the Union were a professional
and lower than general features
including foreign language interpreters
America doctors legal clark's
accountants geometers geomancer's court
painters and scribes the changeable clan
was one of these prominent families who
Adams grandfather quoting proof for the
Chinese religion to better had three
sons or a boon became official foreign
language interpreters they were Kwang
soo Jung hee and no term and Guzman
father turned to his own creation and
co-eds father long term passed the
translators a determination and served
as interpreter
so the parameter was the father of
tomato he in 1881 he had gone to change
in China as one of 20 students a
companion community there he learned
English language making see one of his
the first English speakers in Korea so
in 1883 he visited the United States as
a member of window mix Korean mission so
it had sea turtle he also had an
interest in heart and participated in
the viewing art and then finished in his
poetry society Guido was born in 1886
his well-traveled father inspired
Guido's interest in arts and foreign
culture at the age of 13 who we don't
enter the hands on French school where
he learned French and when tomorrow
there he also saw the French psalmist
report memmio who sketched the French
language teacher Emily Emily Martin
Guido was amazed a fluid manner in which
various tracker strokes for trained
feeders and it was from this two
Frenchmen that Co became acquainted with
Western painting and it was his
acquaintance that influenced him to
later go to Tokyo in 1904 after four
years at the hands of Francesco who was
appointed a junior officer at the office
of money from Africa however after the
birth of protection treaty was signed in
1905 making Korea Protectorate object
who you know now 19 years old decided
that working as a Oberman officer
wouldn't have a meaningful he wrote the
country had lost his dignity
there was nothing one could do the I let
go of all that was in my mind and decide
to immerse myself in the world of
painting and he don't know by then at
the age of 22 he enter stand painting
under two 2004 painters and June ship
and so this is his painting of me
bowing to rock that who painted a little
salmon this is one of the oldest
painting holding under Angie energy but
certain Ramez traditional method of
volume painting was to copy all the
ministers paintings according to this
inscription who painted this painting
imitating his teacher and June shifts
from painting of the same subject the
painting shows the typical way of
painting training for chosen painters
however from the beginning of who Edo
was not very happy with a churchman way
love vol 2
in fact in 1934 for we don't literally
complain that the traditional Korean
painters were unaware of talk about
creativity with all things Chinese in
the idea and no attempt to go beyond
them so please go ahead from this
statement we did not approve of the
traditional method of learning how to
paint by copying the word masters
painting and he disdained the
conservative and pretentious attitude
toward painting his part by the blond
appreciators in 1909
Kodama Japan to attend the doctor School
of Fine Arts and became the first Korean
person to study western-style
kt dinner who studied under professor
Garuda's haiti who studied in western
style athenian friends and after he
returned to japan he established the
department of western style painting at
the Turkish combined arts teaching the
styles of the neo-classicists french
academy
from 1909 to 1915 who don't endure in
the western style painting department
and land with painting three of his old
portraits deathly just self-portrait
with a head was painted in 1915 at his
age of 30
older graduates have more graduates had
their self-portrait to the school and
this was post graduation work which is
in the collection of the school now
called the Tokyo National University of
Fine Arts and Music here we see a young
woman wearing a traditional blue cream
jacket and untraditional head knowing
his painting would represent Korea to
future students and preparatory school
who proudly identified himself as a
Korean literati by wearing traditional
attire to other self-portraits from the
same leader and now in the National
Museum of Contemporary Art so after six
years of schooling in Japan freedom
returned Korea he soon established
himself as a pioneer in the
incorporation of Western styles into
Korean painting in the colonial period
and into the post reparation era he
became a giant in the Korean artistic
community heading artists organizations
organizing as
decisions leading artistic exchange
delegations to foreign countries and
even serving yourself prominent figure
in a barrier yourself political parties
however while he was the first Korean
artist to paint in western style whose
interest in Western art was selective he
noted although I loved western-style
painting I was more interested in his
scientific theory but I was not attached
to masturbate himself what fascinated
him was the scientific approach and the
methodology underlying Western painting
which involves close observation of
nature and is recreated by the artist in
fact after 1926 who stopped oil painting
instead he returned to the professional
oriental painting media of him and
colors on paper or silk he introduced a
new kind of art which synthesized
Western painting methods and techniques
with Korean children painting cuckoo his
own two things were very important first
was to honor the unique particularity of
the painting subject vilensky
and second was the creativity of the
artist although who painted the main
subjects through his life he favored
Diamond Mountain Wednesday which I will
discuss later in the talk after six
years as an artist who died in 1965 18
in 2005 the National Trust rescued
Gordon's house fledge studio in which he
had lived and worked for 41 years
the house was slated for demolition but
instead after four years of reservation
it was restored and now served as poet
on his gallery there he had lots of
gatherings with his friends and whose
relationship with his friends were very
important because these friends were
important and influential figures in the
history of Korean art and Korean history
one of the hoodoos lifelong friends was
like 90 through the tunnel like Amitabh
Bachchan came from anniversaries of
genii family the hedgehog planet
Oh st. Anne's father Otto serve as a
translator interpreter and resort
collector and enlightened intellectual
likewise was at Tom became an
intellectual nationalist an independence
fighter during the colonial period in
the public saw Art Basel Chuck was an
email in River Park columns work and art
historian who wrote a very important
book called William Watty by relatives
of Korean
because of their similar to in
background and mutual interest in art
even though who said tom was 20 years
older but we don't who he don't it was a
time were close throughout their lives
another friend is worth the mention is
James who was from prominent publisher
history and and leading member of the
Korean independence movement like oozing
tongue and whom he don't channel
something from a Chilean family and
studied in Japan check published credits
first model diverging when he founded
that the first issue who did
illustration such innocent travel mm
Martin and found it to be very
meaningful and symbolic place which
could restore the nationalist pride of
Korean people who we do need a statement
as we will discuss more later in the
talk another of course friends was
childhood kid who was twenty years his
junior
this is picture from 1938 when the
Oaxaca the former name of the kinds of
Art Gallery opened the guava opened with
a collection of the young Korean
collector tone young kid who strove to
preserve Korean art treasures and
massive pieces and prevent them from
leaving the country mr. John Young
killed himself is a critical figure in
Korean art history but guido was close
associate with mr. Jang and helped him
present
artistic advisor in compiling his
collection so Gordo and his friends like
to do drink and discuss art and politics
and more here is a painting of gathering
of Goya Tom and his friends
according to coherence son this is a
gathering box if I'd caught one
digitally like padlet types
so here the three of them are identified
his son who is in the Sun so with a long
beard is hoid on there and next codon is
janam son recently SRB home and next to
channel Sun is a channel and these three
figures have been identified by a KO son
but I think one on the far left appears
to be the painter Antonio and here's the
picture window a home that looks
somewhat like a finger in the painting
Anita was cost lifelong friend and only
sometimes Larry
with his friends go and eat sometimes
who ever participated in critical
artistic culture and political
activities
now having briefly outlined the
political system as the context of
Korean painting during course our
leaders I'd like to discuss the history
of I'm a mountain and paintings
depicting so come come time where
diamond mountain is located on the east
coast of North Korea and is one of the
best-known who knows mountains in the
country the miniguns am literally is
Thailand or the sensory world Basra
meaning diamond went on the road about
rice Buddhist ritual object representing
firmness of spirit and spiritual power
the mountain countries are almost
entirely of granite a very hard stone
whether withered over centuries into
wide variety of shapes including over
12,000 picturesque stone formations come
grandson has many different names
conganga and sleep medicine
summer tanaka-san
forum and diamond Martin has been
considered a sacred mountain since the
late Torah dynasty though his
significance becomes has changed over
time during the murder dynasty it was
believed that Don Bogota Bodhisattva
resided on that mountain
therefore many Buddhist temples and
monasteries are sited on the mobile - it
has only been an important pilgrimage
site the Chinese envoys to Korea made
time to visit and pay homage at the
Buddhist temples and endure the monster
mountain sickness during the joseon
dynasty when confession became the
ruling ideology of Korea and Buddhism
was suppressed by my laundry was a place
for official scholars and artists to
enjoy scenic beauty and BC aspirations
for their foreign travel Turner's and
others from the 18th century all through
the total dynasty the mountain you can
create conservative of trivalent state
painting in the colander clearly it
became a physical symbol of Korea's
adamantine natural spirit and integrity
ironically despite the spiritual and
nationalistic significance to the print
people Diamond Mountain was
simultaneously famous tourist that for
the Japanese
so time amounting is commonly divided
into three areas inner conga nagging
gone out Iringa and single or heckled it
should be the differential Joel Bartko
talker and talk about the features I
will not show the typical traveling
veterinary of Diamond Mountain so this
is where the the preparatory stars at
the combine oh we can burn which keeper
kind of looking on that a diamond
mountains and getting ready for their
trips
turrets and go to another district
Romans huh
one important work back to water falls
and there are eight pawns and
and that's up
you know is the fighter China kid which
is the highest
Pisa position
area
I'll turn
in order to see
so so let's show the pictures of those
sites and as well as some true beautiful
paintings of the first to stop time
times huh
with his monastery and with young go
there and to Anza and my
then the by Ratana peak were given and
they moved to the wiggler after example
and there are no parade pools some part
down and nine drivable okay so this
became this always has been a great
subject for both traditional and
contemporary for South and North Korean
artists
so this is the most well-known attribute
into a pinewood mountain for complete
view of Diamond Mountain stanza here he
encapsulated are mounted in a circular
competition using spiky middle like
brushstrokes to depict Diamond mountains
granite rocks and cliffs in the light
area on the right side and wet brush
strokes to depict the leafy polish in an
almost equally balanced dark area on the
left side it is thought symbolizes the
imminent loss of a thousand seeds so we
kind of briefly look at the color
paintings before going on Stein and
Guido and diamond mountains who visited
Diamond Mountain separate times he first
went there in 1911 with his painter
friend Edwin in 1918 after the
establishment of the Korean art Artists
Association he visited the mountain with
misleading members including aceton and
drew general subject who went back
several more times and expressed his
admiration for the mountain as a mess of
pure unique
during the colonial period when you
paint Diamond Mountain the mountain had
literally become a mountain of
contradiction promoted for is
superficial features ethical by son and
for his profound patriotic petrotech
spiritually by others the colony
government was keen to develop our
tourism industry in Korea which included
a Diamond Mountain cycling program in
1931 the Japanese colony government and
who was an electric railway
incorporation complete the railway for
the conduction band and this short to
the journey to Diamond Mountain from
Seoul which used to pick one ones that
were to one week in addition to this
railway a lot of modern penology such as
the Kuna hotel was built in a round
diamond mountain that this brought
numerous tourists Korean Japanese and
Westerners to the mountain meanwhile
many Korean intellectuals and artists
deplored died do I do that
Diamond mountains had become a mere
sites in sight we're losing its symbolic
meaning automobiles Korean nationalists
consider the diamond mountains to be a
symbol of the Korean spirit and these
Korean under lectures artists and
writers traveled to Diamond Mountain and
published their travel journey and
sketches of diamond
only then Chan am son was one of the
most influential figures he claimed the
time of mountain was inside Livia of
beauty and a unique and killed this
miracle of the world and that having the
diamond mountain in Korea was creates
happiness and heavens pleasant she
argued that diamond mountain was the
physical representation of Korean mind
as well as sacred and civilian presence
that intimately represents free online
culture and history
coumadin also shared this feeling and
ideology with Tenzin
as mentioned earlier even though he was
Korea's first western-style painter who
sought the most realist in paintings and
hewed this long runs and he apparently
to some Western criticism of traditional
Korean art to heart as shown by the
statement who struggled to find a unique
and venerable crannies and delived that
the role of Korean haters was to express
Korea's own beauty and a compelling
spirits from 1927 then was stopped
painting Western world painting and
return to traditional media however even
though he picked up the traditional
measures that is carbon-based Incas
colors and painted on credited side silk
were more varied paper using the
traditional method who did not follow
the traditional Eastern style
philosophy or petty instead he adopted
western-style painting approach and try
to produce realistic or objective
representation of the scenery using
abroad for calorie of techniques that
the earlier painters than the other
painters so
let's get some of dialogue mountains
paintings from the early 1930s who began
his series of diamond mountain landscape
painting which lasted throughout his
life in the 1930s who made sketches and
painted each side faithfully and
realistically and later in the 1940s
when he was not able to travel to
Diamond Mountain anymore due to
political turbulence who continued to
paint Diamond Mountain site based on his
memory and other sketches so these are
some of the diamond mountains paintings
and most of it is extant Diamond Head
mountain paintings are from 1940 he's
aged 62 in this painting of
omnipeek owner home who captures his
granite kicks with a rapidity powerful
and lively Oracle brushstrokes as he
stated in his inscription flashing back
over my past attorney bizarre and
astonishing scenery almost before my
eyes i soothe my troubled mind by
vintages another painting from the third
year of 1947 depicts Samson rock in
ultra diamond mountains towering sharp
and jagged peaks appear to be or most
fantastically bizarre yet compared this
cool photograph of Samson drops the rock
in this painting very closely meaning to
actual profiles of the rocks so even
both
even though who painted this Samson
rocks from his memory he must have had a
very vivid memory for this frequent
visits and close observations who are
repeating the practice of painting
among the many sights of the time Wood
mountain cause favorite subject was
ginger ginger waterfall stand for one of
the eight pawns in mantle water there
are extent who paint there are two
extent who paintings of change upon in
Korea so these are the two our paintings
now in Korea both paintings are painted
on paper the one on the left was painted
in 1940 and the right is in 1946 now
compared to these paintings in subject
matter and competition we can identify
the subject of the East Asian eyelid
painting to beach in Japan in the
mountain let's we'll get the painting in
more details
the painting depicts a worker in a rocky
ravine which should be the left little
bushes a pond below and faraway
mountains in the distance cause quick
port brushstrokes effectively represent
rough granite bodies on the lower right
of the painting there is a two line
inscription saying
painted on summer day in the mirror of
capsule which is 1934 by two pointers
and to sills in fact if we compare
compare this painting with a blip
so this is where ginger dam and in fact
if we are compared is painting with a
black-and-white photograph of ginger
plant from 1930 we could clearly see who
tried very hard to depict the side
faithfully to be sexual features another
point I'd like to address is at how this
painting is done in black ink in light
bar with light colors in silk
however as silk ages and is exposed to
light it becomes young rich and the
colors are faded so it is someone
telling you to know the original colors
this painting from 1944 many better
reflect hosts of color talents
if the 1934 painting is corrected using
current photograph Photoshop technology
for the effects of aged silk and faded
colors than the original may have looked
more like this if so we see a very
dramatic painting that was much too
early 920 century Western art and
perhaps even gives a note to
fled to the pollutant graphic clarity of
black and white horror laughs it is a
board dynamic somewhat masculine
rendition with with the mass as much
space devoted heart deeply shadowed
rocks and literature soft palate the
1940s Evo version by contrast is soft
softer and more feminine with a
morphology and more restful water in sky
and a much more traditionally ancient
mystic competition this 1946 version of
the same C is highly impressionistic
with a little attention to detail
reminiscent of traditional amateur
attractive hinting nonetheless the bold
dynamism and little negative space are
perhaps more Western in approach in any
case this different interpretation of
the same scene shows that caused quite
experimental but but despite his Western
of activism has caused last physical
contact made of coalesced physical
contact with a mountain and worked from
diminishing memories the paintings
necessarily became less observed and
more imagined with reflex reference to
exaggeration mental models the Asian is
the East Asian average engine done
painting is significant influence first
even though we know that
Corky and his time a mountain landscape
painting in the early 1930s
do painting that we know to renew to the
other diamond mountain scene from the
nineteen thirties Higa Justin to see his
painting style that is until is painting
what identified
however as we place was three Jinju pond
and inside fire style we see his
experiment experimentation and
development of styles
therefore this 1934 painting is a very
important work to show what ghosts I'm a
mountain painting was like in his early
period when he was closest to his
mountain experience and to his training
and second then more interested fact is
that the ginger plant painting is highly
likely cause community who are five
subjects in dire mountains which he
displayed in the 1934 Korean artist
Association exhibition now painting is
only known by this picture from a
contemporaneous 1934 Chosun Ilbo
newspaper the picture was included in
the review of the exhibition art critic
Enzo and so Jung commented that Hui
Thomas painting has little effect from
color but captures the home of the
object mixing with the drawing and also
what's that course sets a challenge
appropriate solution painting
unfortunately other than an uncommon and
very towards photograph new rich
lacquered of course 1934 exhibition
painting was found new measurement of
size and no media visible so so what I
did was to take the newspaper photograph
and the painting transparency
so this is a transparency from the truth
on Yahoo and this is one from the
collections and I kind of
put them together
so as you can see they are essentially
identical so I would say this painting
is indeed the painting the Korean artist
Ria's wrong thought he lost
this painting was donated by a Korean
student group to the station library in
the 1930s further investigation on the
creature variety of this ginger ginger
campaign team needs to be done okay in
some who we don't begin his Diamond
mountain landscape with to attendez in
mind along with other naturalist
intellectuals he believed that diamond
mountain is the symbol of Korean spirit
and product also with this ornate I will
mountain landscape characterized by
close observation and unfettered style
he actualized that I sense of his
painting philosophy that is the
particularly of the subject and the
creativity of the painter but ginger
done painting here is a very important
piece of understanding Ramadan that is
world thank you
thank you so much that was such an
incredible Tom Yam the work that you put
into that I'm so grateful to you at this
point we'd like to go ahead and show
them
I'm so happy and thank you very much for
restoring this gift for cleaning and
when I first started work here in 1969
I didn't know there was two Korean
paintings hanging in the front but the
top of the hour door and my friend came
over it you know you have Eden and
cojito painting I said what then I began
to that so it and that that wasn't my
pride as a Korean ever since and time
has passed and it was moved around after
renovation it had been taking off from
there anyway I'm not gonna talk too much
and I'm so happy and thank you very much
for restoring this paintings and thank
you very much for finding out I didn't
know you know that's who brought it and
when it was painted and I thank you very
much
I'd like to thank dr. Hughes for
inviting me to skate this evening and
I'd like to describe for you the work of
the conservation department at Columbia
and how we care for artworks and
artifacts in the university library's
collections after that I'll describe the
conservation treatment that was carried
out for our painting by the artist
kovaydin that we've just heard so many
interesting things about thanks to dr.
Kenneth the Columbia University
library's preservation department is one
of the oldest programs in North America
to care for library collections the
central department of conservatives
performs conservation treatment analyzes
documents and monitors light temperature
and relative humidity in all of the
library's collections storage areas
these collections spend 22 libraries in
the system and included not only books
and documents but also paintings
sculpture and ethnographic objects the
CV Starr East Asian library is one of
five separate distinctive and special
collections in group the conservation
staff at Columbia specializes in
treating paper-based collections
including rare books prints and artworks
such as this hand scroll which was
carefully mended and restored to
readability in our lab
the library's collections are in
frequent demand for loan to museums
across the country and around the world
and when items travel conservators
prepare amounts for display and oversee
packing and transport this example of a
medieval medieval manuscript from the
Rare Book and Manuscript library
required humidity control packaging to
keep it stable during transport
conservation of three-dimensional
objects is a distinct specialty so our
team understands requirements for care
and safe storage and can fabricate
housings such as the one on the right to
preserve artifacts and make them easy to
access for study remember left we didn't
do however we only intervene to treat
items that we are trained to work on so
when objects textiles or paintings
require treatment we hope to identify
the correct specialist to carry out this
work this Bunraku figure in the
collections that star was treated for us
by an expert in objects conservation
based in New York and that was Samantha
Alderson of the American Museum of
Natural History
the painting kumgang voce mica we don't
represented a special example of the
treatment that the libraries would
outsource to a specialist conservator
the university's records show as we've
heard that the painting was donated to
star in the 1930s by the Columbia Korean
students group when this painting was
first viewed in the conservation
department that exhibited tears losses
and staining method you can see here
some of the major areas of loss there
are other smaller ones that it's
probably hard to see but this is
obviously before the the treatment began
to properly care for this important work
by a Korean artist the involvement of
many people was critical
mr. Jimmy Chang the director of CV Starr
East Asian library and the custodian of
this painting was eager to improve its
condition professor Theodore use of the
East Asian languages and cultures
department at Columbia gave much of his
time to the planning of this treatment
and his department's financial support
made the treatment possible the New York
firm Asian paintings conservation with
principal conservator Hisashi Taguchi
and partner Jennifer Perry
the East Asian Phoenix conservator at
the Metropolitan using the art were
available to provide the expertise
needed to improve the paintings
condition the availability of talented
specialists in the New York area meant
that this artwork did not have to travel
in its fragile state that was very
important to all of us dr. Eleanor Hyun
and dr. Soyoung Lee curators with
specialized knowledge of Korean art
history served as consultants on this
project kindly sharing their expertise
in meeting with the conservators and
advising us on aesthetic choices so it's
my privilege to describe the
transformative treatment carried out by
my colleague mr. Lee coochie I'll first
give you a brief overview of the entire
treatment and then I'll discuss just a
few of the steps in more detail so
during the paintings treatment in the
Asian paintings conservation studio in
New York it was first gently cleaned and
staining was reduced losses in the
original were filled with new material a
new wooden under core panel was prepared
by the conservator and given multiple
linings this is important because of
painting on fragile silk such as this
one always will remain sensitive to
changes in humidity so that the humidity
is very dry it can contract with too
much humidity of expense and this could
even cost tearing or very serious damage
so the multiple linings that the
conservator applied will help it to
withstand fluctuations as much as
possible
so that's that we're seeing it before
application to the panel here so after
the stage that we're seeing this is a
during treatment photograph after this
new silk quarters needed to be applied
and then the painting could be adhered
to the panel that I've just described
and inserted into explain
so here we can see an example of the
conservators sensitive treatment of one
of the areas of loss you can see that
new material has been added in the lower
photograph on the right to fill the
missing areas and it's been toned to
blend visually with the overall image of
the painting at the same time it's just
visible so with careful close
examination and informed viewer is able
to distinguish between new and older
material that's an inflatable in the
treatment none of the original paint was
touched up in any way during the course
of the treatment but in some areas there
was loose paint that had to be very
carefully reappeared delicate
painstaking work the work of our group
of collaborators was especially
important in the choice of his silk
orders in their color under the
suggestion of our consultants mr. Iguchi
discussed the optimal silk order with
his colleague in Korea professor buck
ji-sun who generously provided her
opinion for us that a plain weave silk
would be the most appropriate
replacement since we could not replicate
the original and also because this
painting was a modern work and the
experts in our group agreed with this
suggestion and
carrying out this plan we were again
very fortunate in the generosity of
Professor Parker who kindly shared with
us some of her own silk that had been
hand-woven in Korea for projects of her
own that she felt would be a suitable
aesthetic replacement the opinions of
the art historians in her group were
solicited as to the correct color that
the conservator would dye the new silk
for the outer borders the choice of
color was based upon a celadon green
color of the old silk that was revealed
during treatment this was an area that
was not exposed to light so as the
mountings were taken off you could see
what the color had been in addition an
inner border silk and you can see here
with chosen to reflect the pattern of
the existing one a new frame was created
by the conservator but the old frame
components that had been removed have
been saved and carefully stored should
they be needed for future study and
they're here in the starti station
library with the painting the painting
will become in a prominent and
environmentally suitable location the
crest reading room of the CV Starr East
Asian library the collaboration of an
international group of scholars and
conservators meet the project to treat
wounds on PO che a truly global effort
I'm grateful that thanks to the support
of the East Asian languages and cultures
department at Columbia and the
participation of so many experts we
could obtain such a skillful and
sensitive treatment allowing for us to
care us to care for the important part
work that has been entrusted to us
Wow there are a lot of people here you
can't tell from when you're sitting in
the front so thank you for all coming
can you all hear me
great it's always actually a pleasure to
come back to Colombia cos as an alumna
at the college and graduate school of
Arts and Sciences it's always like
coming back home that's quite nice and I
was really honored when I was approached
to consult on this project for that
reason and also now coming back with
time and distance the memories of
toiling away in this library and in a
breeder gotten easier so the good
memories that are serving which is
always nice so I'm just gonna briefly
because following these really wonderful
presentations of the historical
background of core and the process of
the conservation I'm just going to just
speak very briefly on some of the
conversations that I had with he's
actually routine sort of sort of
unveiled and the conversations that
happened before you do conservation
treatments and reframing and remounting
the issues that are often raised in
these conversations and the decisions
that follow from them so here then is
the picture of the before and the after
and you see that there's quite a
difference thankfully and the main
concern of any kind of conservation
project or the word that came to my mind
I was thinking about my talk today was
suitability or appropriateness what is
suitable what is appropriate when you
sort of intervene in
conserving and remount to give reframing
the work and there are different levels
of things that you have to be concerned
with the suitable suitability
intervention how much do you do to a
work how much do you want to conserve
and place in and that's what Alexis is
so wonderfully talked about in ensuring
the in painting and how much you want to
cover and how much you want to show when
viewers see this
what kind of work has been done and then
the suitability in terms of the art
historical accuracy of these new remount
teams and the conservation that you're
doing so in this you see this before and
after and you can tell that we haven't
really moved so far away from the actual
frame and the framing the frame and
maybe the mounting that was done before
and we'll and I'll briefly talk about
why here what's often interesting is
that when you look at objects as an art
historian or in books and on even on the
Internet
you're often seeing objects like this
paintings without their frames without
their mountings always it's the spit
painting itself so oftentimes we as
we're often not trained to think about
the mounting because it's not really
presented to us when we study them and
it's only when you go to museums we've
seen their exhibitions that they're
mounting in the frame becomes much more
prevalent to our experience of
viewership but in these kinds of
presentations like I'm showing you here
or in the books that you look at
look at reproductions of objects the
frame and then the opportunity is often
excluded which makes it then harder to
sort of decide what you want to do and
so then going back and doing the
research and thinking about the
paintings again the one image that I
found on live from the southern
university that Professor Cammie talked
about also did not show its current
friends and devices so I don't actually
you know what it's its current frame and
mountain looks like and this one that's
in Korea isn't it going on home museum
and this is in amount some sort of
mounting with the frame so that gives us
a better clue and types of mounting
techniques that are used for his works
and then I thought we can do a little
bit of thought process the thought
experiment because this painting was
painted in 1934 in Kuwait on in 1924
although he's the first painter to have
been trained in western painting
techniques and oils in 1925 he decides
that when it comes back to Korea in this
in Korea that he wants to now only paint
with traditional inks and we sort of
abandoned his Western oil painting kind
of materials and with that then you can
think oh is a traditional mounting more
appropriate for this type of painting
and so this is sort of the thought
experiment that I'm showing here is that
I just superimpose the koi don't
painting in what would be more of a
traditional mounting style for st.
Vincent's chosen period painting and you
can see how very different the
experience would be if they're mounting
this this way versus the what we see
right here so you do see how the frame
really affects the way people view and
interact
objects and then but me in the end
decided to keep I shouldn't even have
this picture I should just keep on
pointing obviously the bedroom this is
not the reproduction and one of the
reasons behind me decided to keep it in
this thing the same style of framing and
mounting that that it was in before is
because we've found the record that had
come into the collection in the 1930s so
this older style excuse me that the the
original frame and the mountain was
therefore age-appropriate or heiress
appropriate because we knew that it was
maybe not from 1934 but it was actually
from the 30s so this really reflects the
framing styles of that period so we
thought instead of trying to do
something maybe that would be completely
might be beautiful but not actually
accurate we decided to keep with the
mounting and the frame and then if you
do look back at some of these older this
is these are some newspapers of the
1930s showing different kinds of
exhibitions like Professor Kim had had
shown and you do see that their frames
were you so it wasn't that during this
time period
obviously this frames weren't using
there's only this traditional style so
it gives us in hanging these time
Asians sort of an assurance that we're
going in the right suitable or
historical historical situation you see
here's another one of these exhibitions
from the 1830s and then again it was
about color so now we have to make
choices about what kinds of colors would
be appropriate and therefore it makes me
think about not only do have to be
appropriate artists or clean for the
historic time period of the piece but
also you have to be appropriate in the
choices you make for the current state
of the object you can't be thinking
about the painting I didn't even know
that we were gonna do this but professor
women first Atkins in her photoshopping
of this painting to what might have been
the original colors if we had had made
those choices to that color scheme then
that might not be appropriate and
suitable for actually the current state
of this painting which is which has aged
as all of all of us do with time so I'm
with that and seeing that the original
color of this silk was more like this
this darker top green that's in this in
this slide which was which was part
what's closer to the color of the
original silk that hadn't been affected
by the light we thought you did put that
kind of borders that border on it which
is what I'm showing here versus what
he's actually he what you do which is he
brought the tone down a little bit so
that it would actually be a better sort
of color fit with the actual painting
and so you see here's what he what he
said again we should just look right
here you should see me standing right
here so it's it's not as mean it's not
as brilliant with that
because it's a better appearing for the
current state at me so they didn't have
to also think about the suitability of
the choices you're making not for maybe
the original painting and in its
original state but what you have right
now and and so that was the reasons
behind what has now become this
incredibly beautiful painting and I'm so
proud to have been part of this
consultation team and the other thing I
was just thinking about with this whole
project was that not only was it global
and in the terms of the team that was
around it but the painting itself is
obviously a meeting of corridos Korea
West his own kind of global moment in
the frame also represents that with a
wooden frame a western-style type of
frame with an inner silk border that is
more of a traditional East Asian Paints
so there's no sort of a global Innes to
this painting from its permit severity
of existence to the project that we have
today so thank you so much
thank you so much we do have some time
for questions so if anyone would like to
ask you can ask a question of a specific
presenter and that person can kinda come
up and and respond
in the yeah
but calling what we know is the waitress
finding side library only records we
have now it's a donate to the library by
the Korean student group in the 1930s we
don't have exact date when I came here
in 1969 I saw the painting hanging there
then I asked the people who were here at
the Columbia around 1930 and they said
that they donated lot of Korean books to
try to open the Korean section of a
library here so I think with that lot of
books and a painting or King so that's
two very important paintings on his
columns and that the other ones either
ximenos lady in a wedding so it starts
there I don't know if it still dances
yes
it's hanging there now yes
it's been a related to this perspective
for us as a family during your research
you find any kind of clue as to half of
18 left 3 up and into New York City
tanana's student funny all the way to
study here I cannot imagine bringing a
yellow basket it was like that so do you
find anything that people are anything
thanks for addressing that issue which I
am still kind of struggling to find out
more so I pick up a time I didn't really
show this but me I have a problem you
just
so I had a very similar questions when
did he come to the station light
reflection why Columbia and how did they
miss turnstile you know we're under a
culinary like Japanese or you know a
patient that Princeton's had a fund
raising and you know donated the work to
the museum in the question so and thanks
to Korean Studies library and Keith
Chien actually gave me some tips to wear
to the floor and there I found out the
Korean student blood cells which he is
from like 1920 some years and there I
found really interesting articles and
let's see and this is the picture that
is current student Federation's now have
a reunion event galleries in New York
and there are many other and of these
galleries in Chicago and
other places so there were your patio
Stern groups with student groups and the
second one was this world from 1931 how
can I
and this is say 1931 Korean culture
center established at Columbia
and phone dream all Christian Christians
realize the commit community plans to
make it the finest best of the kind in
America and there's also a Korean
cultural center established and that
they kind of asked for donations and
support and I also found very
interesting kind of an article here
and he's very clean and an efficient of
painting by miss crane I have identified
who she is who has been devoting her
talent to candy Korean scenery was held
recently at the Pune alias in Seoul and
by the widow connections who we don't
use to be a journalist and both columns
receipts will be used to purchase
so I can kind of see not you know the
you that leak but I can see the hills
here and there about Columbia University
Library and Priya student associates and
you know art exhibition of me strain in
you know beautiful buildings and also
near the maintenance sure so suggest the
people need that fimo kimonos painting
very like you know Haiti was also
donated to Harvard University about the
same time so I requested oh I sent an
email to the Registrar there to find out
if they have the exact date of the
village
so that was my fight
in the catalog resume
the audience's work where does this
begin right here
and
that's a question to answer about
ranking I hate to say compared to other
images time to mountains I would say as
as I said this is the only dated from
1930s and so he kind of shows I think
it's very hard to kind of rank or
evaluate the works because he kind of
developed his style from 1930s to 1950s
in very good ways from more kind of real
estate and retinal illusionistic to more
abstract but I would say this is very
creek or kiss to understand the very
ordinary kind of style he's painting the
landscape paintings
it
you talk we mentioned these words
repetition
okay I when I meant Dido
so I applied the theory
if you have additional questions we can
certainly you can ask them at the
reception
it usually occur according to the travel
journeys you mean in 1930s or during the
Chosun dynasty
so they can office tornado garment and
stations this way as you can
so there is like not one way of the
point but you can take up making gun
around to our Beckenbauer kingdom so
business way is to painting so use the
red
thank you very much such a wonderful set
of presentations could we get a round of
applause